But what about policies in
commercial environments?
First of all, when you go work for
a company, they might do a background
check on you, but they don't clear
you at secret or top-secret levels.
So clearance is really not common when
it comes to these types of environments.
However, there are other requirements
that may arise in these kind of places.
If we talked about,
we go back to our payroll.
If you are a payroll
department employee,
then you can access applications
that have to do with payroll.
But others should not
be able to do that.
So one requirement could be that data
is accessed by certain applications and
only certain users be able to gain
access to certain kind of applications.
Requirement may be that non-payroll
department people don't have
access to the payroll application.
Other requirements that
arise in these commercial
environments is conflict of interest,
is pretty common.
So if you're a law firm,
have two customers, and
there's some competitive
relations in between those, and
a lawyer working on one case
should not have access to
data that belongs to the other company,
when those two companies compete.
Separation-of-duty typically is good for
reducing the likelihood of fraud.
So if one person can do multiple things,
it's easier for them to commit fraud.
In commercial environments, clearance
is not there, BLP's not very useful,
but perhaps, the need for
mandatory access control is there.
So we want to look at some models
that may make sense in this setting.